[Music]
there's there are trays there's free
agency they're different things that we
all do to try to build our football team
and and you're always trying to do that
and next man up means next man up and
there's going to be a competition for
that spot next man up doesn't mean
you're entitled okay i'm kind of sitting
in the spot this guy's out so here i am
okay i'm the guy that's not really how
it works you're gonna have to compete
for that spot and earn that spot
[Music]
jason garrett head coach of the dallas
cowboys talking about some of his
philosophies that relate to the making
of an nfl team and there's opportunities
at running back with ezekiel elliott
holding out and chris you know the
cowboys
firm i firmly believe
had no real expectation elliot wasn't
going to show up until he didn't show up
and now they are shifting into
business mode where they are saying
things very differently instead of
saying he's the straw that serves our
drink they're saying you don't need the
rushing champion to win a super bowl and
they've signed alfred morris the
question becomes at what point do they
take a more serious approach to this
and uh i had an idea yesterday yep you
know
if if you really want to prepare
for life without ezekiel elliott and if
you really want to upgrade your running
game
so you have somebody who can come in and
take advantage that great offensive line
and be the compliment to dak prescott
why not give a phone call to a division
rival and yes trades happen within
divisions all the time call up
washington and make an offer for adrian
peterson a guy who has said many times
over the years he would like to play for
one of the texas nfl teams whether it's
the texans or the cowboys he was once on
the phone with jerry jones saying i want
to play for the cowboys when i'm done
playing for the minnesota vikings and
now that opportunity would come if the
cowboys would pick up the phone and call
washington and whether it's peterson or
someone else like him you get that kind
of a guy on the roster that allows you
to say to ezekiel elliott hey zeke
you're making 3.8 million this year or
you're not making anything it's up to
you we're not giving you a new contract
you had your opportunity to accept our
best offer you refused we moved on we
welcome you back at 3.8 million but
we're not giving you anything more than
what you're already due to make this
year that would be the ultimate all-in
business move for the dallas cowboys and
i just wonder at what point between now
and the start of the regular season or
into the regular season they make that
move if elliot continues to stay away
well well i mean in theory i agree with
a lot of things you say okay i mean yeah
adrian peterson that would be great if
they could find some way to get him on
their roster at least he's a proven
commodity you know he could be a
workhorse that way still certainly has
some explosion left in his legs and his
body and all that and then even really
look at the optics of the washington
redskins and the running back position
and what they got there they are pretty
deep so like within theory yeah it could
happen but would washington ultimately
really want to trade to a division rival
in a position they know is very
important for that team's success and
give them that advantage that's where i
would just question if that would really
happen and hey
everyone's got a price yeah you're right
cowboys are offering you enough yes then
you say yes to it just like when when
when they traded for donovan mcnabb
right now i think andy reid knew what he
was doing yeah but
hey you know what the price is right
we're going to do the deal yeah no
you're right if there was something that
blew them out of the water they probably
would you're right they're going to go
okay fine you can have adrian peterson
it might help you guys out this year but
the trade's going to help us out for the
next three years so you know i get all
of that now the the big thing is and i
think the realization here with the
dallas cowboys this is the biggest thing
i mean we've talked so much about how
they're built they're built to run the
football maybe okay this one thing has
occurred to me maybe they know something
we don't if they want to draw you know a
hard line in the sand mic maybe they
feel like they're passing offense and
keller moore and the things they're
going to do are going to be able to
carry the offense more this year maybe
but the other thing is i gotta see that
to believe it but the the value of great
running backs okay mike it just can't be
quantified it really cannot because hey
people are gonna watch the dallas
cowboys this preseason and go oh oh look
our running back just ran for five yards
up the middle we don't need that oh
there's another run for five yards it
looks good the running game looks good
the problem is and what can't be
quantified is on those five yard runs
guys like ezekiel elliott or saquon
barkley they make that guy miss and it
becomes a 20 yard run or it becomes a 60
yard touchdown or instead of second and
five now it's first and ten again 30
yards up the field because they had the
explosion or the speed or that physical
gift that got them through the hole
before it closed or they'd be able to
break the tackles that some of those
lower level running backs
can't they can maximize what's there to
be had and that's the greatness and
sometimes can't be seen on a stat sheet
and things like that for people to
really you know kind of take it all in
well the other thing too if you
projected to the regular season the guy
who got that five yard run did it with
no safeties in the box yeah right
because they're focused on taking away
the passing game because you game plan
very differently if it's alfred morris
no disrespect to alfred morris right and
if it's ezekiel elliott running the ball
my point is this yeah if the cowboys are
are determined to play hardball with the
zq elite because they can say that they
don't have to do anything they can say
we've got you under contract for two
more years if you want to stay away stay
away and at some point you're going to
give up game checks and at some point
your your contract is going to kick to
next year that's the thing to remember
this isn't the le'veon bell situation
where you just sit out a year and then
you get to go pick a new team the
cowboys have him under contract for two
more years if he doesn't show up by the
tuesday after week 10 they will still
have him under contract for two years in
2020. it all gets pushed back by one
year so they have a lot of ultimate
power here but the leverage elliott has
in the short term is staying away
staying away into the regular season if
that's what he chooses to do at some
point the cowboys have to ask themselves
do we make alternative plans as part of
this effort to show elliott and all
other current and future cowboys players
we are not to be trifled with when it
comes to our contractual commitments and
and that's where the the ongoing year in
and year out business consideration may
outweigh the short term we need to have
ezekiel elliott consideration yeah i i
hear that but does it outweigh the short
term i'm jerry jones and i'm really old
and my team's in the super bowl window
right now that's where i throw it that's
no disrespect to jerry jones he still
looks really good for an old guy i'm not
saying anything like that but you know
we know he's documented he said it he
wants one more you know he knows he's
coming to the end and everything like
that and you know this team when you
evaluate it and look at it on paper and
look at what it did last year i mean
there's just not a lot of weakness on
the team it's one of the best rosters in
football when you really take the
starting 22 and everything to go with it
but so much of the success revolves
around that run game in ezekiel elliott
and they're putting a lot of pressure
and unknowns on the pass game and kellen
moore if they don't have him and you
know that's one i'd have to see to
believe first
without ezekiel
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports